[Music]
right I mean do lots of practice at home
and now I'm going head-to-head with a
current world-record holder
Darrin what's the secret the secret a
just gotta concentrate relax and just go
for it
concentrate and relaxed right why were
so nervous okay this records he must
produce a minimum of 40 slices and the
time to beat one minute 34 are you ready
yep good luck yes yeah three two one go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Darrin's put me at the post but have
either has got the required 40 slices
I'm gonna count Nate's got the minimum
of 40 right so I'm happy he's got 40
then I'll weigh a selection of what like
this small this one 40 just got there
[Applause]
Darren spot-on with 40 so it's crunch
time for me they look pretty fat
they look pretty fat 6 to 7 38 39 damn
I've only got 39 Darren's beaten me but
has he beaten the world record time of 1
minute 34 today's time
one minute 24 seconds 22 seconds have
you been practicing no not so damn one
slice short but we have a new world
record with this man
[Applause]